The small space lifestyle, you're going to make choices...
...and you end up becoming really conscious of what you bring into your life.
Round tables can be really wonderful because they don't have corners and edges.
The roundness actually makes you feel like it's taking up less volume.
We use transforming furniture in both of the bedrooms...
...because it allows us flexibility.
So, when the kids are not in the bed there's no need for the bed...
...and it gives them more play space,...
...which gives us so much more freedom and flexibility.
Open shelving is another one.
It's gonna make you think about the objects that you buy.
I really believe in these canvas storage bins by Pehr Design.
They're flexible, they can move in any direction...
...and can be folded up and packed flat.
And they're really my secret to how I pull this all off.
I tend to love plants in a space.
They, you know, mirror the outside.
They produce oxygen in the space so it makes a space feel bigger as well...
...because you're taking in more oxygen and more light into your world.
Take a moment to think about what you have...
...and start thinking about how it's serving you in your life, what it means to you,...
...and if there's even one thing you can get rid of today, do it.